[Music]
[Zheng] This is going to be the one.
I can feel it, man.
I can't feel it.
[Music]
Oh. my God! We got it, guys!
Eh, no is this..? No, this is not-
So, right here with us, we have two hot-selling collections:
The Disney Animals, and Yoki's Gemstone Prince
and let's get started on the Disney Animals, shall we?
[Music]
[Zheng] And with the Disney Animals Box Set,
We have actually done our research and
The hidden one here is actually, 'Perdita' from 101 Dalmations
So, let's hope we actually get that.
*Intense Box Slap*
*Mouth Pop* Nice.
[Zheng] Let's go!
*sped up gibberish*
So, this is the feeling of opening a box set
Instead of a single...
A single blind box.
*dramatic box slam*
So, the rituals of unboxing these toys
Of course, you're not supposed to press, hold, or
Squeeze them before you buy,
So, we would recommend you not to do that in-store,
but if you have purchased an entire box set,
You are free to do whatever you want with them
And why not have fun with them as well?
So the blind box has a list of all of the figurines
Displayed here and you can check out the one over here,
It is the hidden one that we'd want to look out for
Even though we have no clue what it looks like, but-
We're just gonna try, and hopefully, get our way
And get our luck with a '101 Dalmations' figurine then.
Some of these figurines actually differ in weight and sizes,
And even design, as you can tell from Bambi
Or even Dumbo,
They are slightly bigger than the rest of the (other) figurines
So, hopefully, we'll be able to try and find out
Which one of these blind boxes belong to either of them
*intense box shaking*
Is it me?
They all look the same.
They all feel the same.
Okay, this feels slightly heavier.
*dramatic box placement*
(At least) two of them have got to be Bambi or...
Or Dumbo, so I'm gonna open this one up.
Straight away.
Let's see if my guess is right.
And if we can get a...
Oh, so it still comes in wrapped packaging.
So, you still don't know what the figurines are.
But, I believe they do have a card inside which tells you
Which figurine this is AND...
*disappointment* oh, no they don't.
*surprised* Oh, they do!
This is Timon!
[Timon] Why do I have to always save your-
AHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHH
[Zheng] Timon has a slightly bigger head so,
It's not too bad.
I think it's uh-
(This) guy is so cute!
Check out the details on this figurine
Especially the water droplet!
And the cute little ladybug on his head
The painting and the sculpting is amazing
For a figurine that's about ten to twenty dollars.
So let's continue unboxing.
And of course, my bets are on these two that we would get either Dumbo or Bambi
But, I might be wrong, I might be right,
Let's get down to it.
I'm not even going to look at the card.
I'm gonna go straight into opening this packet for that Gacha feeling.
Oh, man. I'm wrong again.
*intense screaming*
*laughing*
[Zheng] I'm wrong again!
What do we have here?
We have Marie!
[Marie] I'll show you if I'm a lady or not.
[Zheng] Which I'm not too familiar with, unfortunately.
The reason why it's heavy is because of the cake, I believe.
Check out this accessory that came with Marie!
If you didn't notice it, this is actually made out of felt,
Instead of the usual plastic.
That's the kind of quality that POPMART is trying to put in their toys.
*ohmygod intensifies*
And it's really incredible for something so small to have been able to put
All these details and work into it.
This is awesome!
C'mon man, c'mon!
I got a good feeling 'bout this!
Oh, my God!
*Intense falling*
*laughing in sadness*
Guess I'm not too good at opening and guessing boxes.
What do we have here?
We have- this is, 'Thumper'.
'Thumper with a Flower', there's a flower?
Oh, yeah!
So Thumper comes with a flower and we can kind of
Let him hold this.
And then, this is supposed to go inside his/her hand - I have no clue.
So, check out Thumper's feet!
And even the petals are- it's all extremely detailed,
Painted really well, the quality is top-notch, and even for a
Figurine so small, it's amazing how they can come up with this kind of quality.
Oh, this is, Pumba, from Lion King?
[Pumba and Timon] *screaming*
[Zacky] Yeap!
[Zheng] Awesome!
Small little log- not a log, more like a stump,
That you can place him on.
Oh, this is cute!
Slurping some spaghetti!
*spaghetti eating intensifies*
Some of these accessories are extremely delicate, so you gotta be careful with them,
You don't wanna break them,
So, let's safely and slowly put the fork onto the plate of spaghetti.
And, Voila!
Awesome!
[Music]
And while we already know this is Simba,
Which is, I believe is my favourite out of all these toys
because Simba, c'mon guys!
*Simba gets literally thrown out*
Look at the amazing paint job that they have done here with Zazu!
Even though it is extremely small and extremely cute, there are no smudges,
Everything is smooth, everything is perfect.
I have zero complaints.
And then you can simply put this on Simba.
This is my favourite. This has got to be my favourite.
It IS Bambi!
*waves of laughter all around*
Oh, no. How we have failed.
[Music]
And we have this little butterfly, same like Zazu for Simba,
Extremely well-painted, and detailed.
And we can put a butterfly on top of Bambi.
All you got to do is believe!
What's this?
Let's see if I can feel my way.
Feels like a 'Timothy'.
It is a 'Timothy', guys.
But only because I opened up the package.
[Music]
Timothy is holding up a little cute peanut.
How adorable is that?
It comes with a feather that you can put on top of his hat.
There we go, little Timothy!
[Music]
I can feel it, man.
This is going to be the one.
I can't feel it.
OH, MY GOD!
We got it, guys!
Eh, no is this-
No, this is not...
This is *inaudible*
This is not even a 101 (Dalmations).
Such a disappointment.
That's quality content, right there.
Oh, man. I thought we had the 101 Dalmations.
It IS the 101 Dalmations, but it is not Perdita.
So unfortunate.
That's alright.
[Music]
I just surprised myself for no reason.
And of course, Dumbo, over here.
Over here.
Up over here.
[Music]
Last two, guys, c'mon.
Out of all of these, we don't have: Lady Flower,
And of course, the secret one.
It is two out of three chances-
I like to see that as a high possibility of us getting a secret Perdita from 101 (Dalmations).
It is not Perdita from 101 (Dalmations).
But we have Lady with us here.
And she looks really cute and really elegant in a really nice pose.
No accessories involved.
The last one guys, this has got to be the one.
This has got to be the one.
I believe.
If you believe, things are gonna happen, man.
Actually, it does- I'll be honest,
It doesn't feel like (a) flower.
This is it guys, the moment of truth.
Are we gonna get it?
We didn't get it.
*disappointment ensues*
We got scammed!
[Music]
Alright, so we here we go, we have the entire box set,
Right in front of us.
So, if you don't want replicas or repeats, or buying one box at a time,
Go for the entire set, and you'll get every single one of the
Collectible figurines in the box sets, but unfortunately, we didn't get ourselves
One of the secret edition: 101 Dalmations - Perdita
But that's alright, maybe we can get one more box?
Not too sure about that but, yeah
We will be moving on to the next box.
[Music]